yeah just a tiny tiny little note before
we get stuck in actually solving this
I'm calling these emphasis on I I am
calling these indeterminate partial sums
this is not a on this is not like a
proper term but like the way partial
sums is a proper term the reason I call
you indeterminate is because the answer
for this will change based on what n is
right and I guess I could have used the
word variable um the point is this is a
partial Sun like you see it's finite I
want some part of it right but the
length of this partial sum can change
okay if I pick n equals three or four or
five or five hundred the length of the
Sun will change the value of the cells
will change so there is something about
it which can change its not determinate
in other ways and indeterminate of word
that's used in mathematics in a variety
of ways but it always means something
like this okay it's like we're not sure
but we can still work with it okay so
i'm going to show you not one not two
but three ways to solve this question
okay and the three ways are all about
trying to tackle it from different
angles based on the kinds of stuff but
you know so being that it's a partial
Sun okay what do we know about the total
value of a partial Sun we are young we
have a phobia for these things right
what's the formula yes son ok now just
pause for a second I can either write rd
of minus one or i can write 1 by this
are to the end now i'm just going to
spoil it slightly and kind of a loser
the fact that in this particular case
writing it's this way is going to be
more useful to me you'll discover that
pre random girl ok so if this is what I
know right this is kind of like we we
spent time to develop this formula so it
might as well use it right let's see how
i'm going to put together with this now
i'm going to make a tiny little note you
can see I've got to UM example questions
on the board that one I'm not really
going to spend time doing I just want
you to have a go at it on the basis of
the tools that we develop here I prefer
to write the question like that there's
only a very very subtle difference width
and this one lately my choice of
variable okay or choice of printable i
should say right i prefer to use case up
here rather than ends can anyone suggest
to be wide you know not that you have to
but why this might be a good job okay
good this end this ad Marcus very
carefully this end is completely
different from this end and this end
right this just forget this series it is
for a second what does add me in this
popular no returns how many formula the
simon terms are in this series is
partial sum right so this is the sum of
the first n terms but there are not in
terms of this in fact part of the
challenges question is how many terms
are there right i am going to stick with
the end produ rule because this is what
the question is head of it's an HSC
question if i remember correctly ok so
I'm going to just go with it but in
future if you get a choice I prefer to
do it this way so don't have two
variables that have the same day which
is just recipe for confusion okay all
right so I'm going to try and use this
thing on this there's some easy parts to
it and like over to there are some hard
part so first let's do the easy part
what's the first time 33 the M that's
not too complicated just read it off the
ratio is a little bit harder but not
that much what is taking me from one
term to the next it's negative 3 okay uh
you know it's a three firstly because
you can see these powers rising which
means i'm getting extra tray every time
and you know it's negative because of
this alternating side business okay so
far so good now rather than write n
equals okay i just talked out this
before because i'm gonna if i wrote any
cause i'm going to have my ed equals
something which has to do with em which
isn't equal to n i'm going to say how
many terms now rather than just give you
the answer i want to unpack for you how
I think about this kind of question
which will guide you through whether it
looks a bit different okay how many toes
well I think about this first by looking
at this guy over here 3m right this is
kind of like my last index ok now this
question is hard but an easier question
which I could compare this two years if
I started at three into the power of one
I think I would if that was my first
term if 3 to the 1 were the first term
and it's worth thank you this is an
element because it usually is something
to power what usually is the first term
then how many toes a debian total
there'd be 3 to the 1 2 3 4 5 all the
way up and would finish on 3n right so
if i had that whole series happy toes
other there would be 1 2 3 4 5 6 all the
way up to 3m right there would be 3m
terms does that make sense so if through
where the first term there would be 3n
terms ok so that's what would be the
case in it like a simple kind of
situation but that's not the situation
right I'm missing a whole bunch of terms
off the beginning of here because theta
1 is in fact not my first term ok howdy
terms am I missing oh but I am missing
now what are the actual terms are
missing the ones i began with 3 to the 1
3 squared three cube dot dot now what's
the last term that gets dropped off to
get the series that i actually want what
is the immediately preceding term right
here it would be 3 to the N minus 1
right do you see that because then the
next one because I'm just going up by
one each time then the next one will be
through in the end the one that I
actually start with right so therefore
the last term that I in vertical is
missing is 3 through have in low five
okay in other words that n minus 1 terms
that's how many I've sliced off are you
okay with that so therefore
healthy toes will actually have right
well it would have been 3n if I'd
started at one from the end but it
doesn't start from 1 i'm missing a whole
bunch of terms how many that me right so
it's going to 38 and i'm going to take
away the number is seeing terms and buy
this one you okay with that do you see
how I'm trying to unpack it so therefore
there are can take away and which is to
add what's the double date of class one
terms are you happy with that see I'm
unpacked it okay I guess another way I
think about is I'm just trying to avoid
this off by one error which is sort of
easy to have when you think our it ends
on 3n and it starts at em an easy common
mistake to meet is going 3m take away
and that just gives you 2m like half the
people who get this role will make that
single misstep this shows you that
there's an extra term that you've missed
right namely the air on the front ok any
questions on that before I move on yeah
so this one here shop so let's the way I
get this is to go back to this like why
did I introduce what I'm missing well I
thought about it in terms of a simpler
series right one that starts at an
obvious point and ends at an obvious
point okay so if I start at one for
instance and end at ten then I know
there's one two three four I don't have
to kill all the numbers in there I know
there's gonna be 10 times okay so if I
started at one and ended at 3n I don't
need to count I just say well there's
three n terms that's what might be the
case but it's not the case I didn't
start a one i started in so i was trying
to answer the question of all how much
has been taken off the front how much do
i need to remove so i get the actual
series of God and this is the number of
terms that i'm missing from the front
right I 1 2 3 all the way up to n minus
1 because that would be one before this
term right n minus 10 then invite us to
all the way down to one okay so if I
knew the last term in this series is n
minus 1 I don't need to count again it's
just like one to ten
except the 10 is not ten its inmost one
so if it's one all the way up to n minus
one that's how many terms I've got just
that number on the year all right thank
you great yeah question we did like um
song from 1-10 he said this one line is
this one plus one yep so coming to 3 and
minus yep so you're thinking 3n take
away in and then just add one yeah yeah
you absolutely can you absolutely can't
now there's a reason why I haven't done
that okay and the reason why is because
in a different scenario you don't add
one you take away one or you add to or
you take away to that approach of just
saying I'll just add one will only work
in this exact scenario and if I give you
a slightly different one it will not it
might work for this one I'm three but
for a different reason okay you see like
I said it'll work but for a different
reason which i think is exactly what you
must avoid doing don't remember a
process that happens to magically work
like but what is it work I'll tell you
really quickly now the reason why it
works here is for this right the reason
why you add one over here is because do
you notice i start at a positive number
k and i'm actually climbing down here
right I'm going down k minus 2k Moses
s'okay much 1k motet drop down through
the minus 2k the reason why I add one
here is because of this the reason I add
one here is because there's a 0 term 320
do you see to go from positive to
negative I've gotta pass through zero so
there's a 320 term in the middle now you
see you add one but four completely
different reasons so I think that's a
really bad like oh yeah i'll just add
one but why like that's the
understanding that i'm missing okay yeah
was this little work if it was
okay was named ah I'm glad you asked
that and I think I'm going to let you
how to go at this when you have a look
at more what actually takes place when I
papi 0 negative numbers what does that
mean is it still meaningful is the
question okay that's a question best
answered for each particular one which
for now we don't need to worry about
because as you can see I'm transitioning
from n all the way to 3n I stayed the
positives all the way okay right those
are good questions and you want ask
anything else before we march on okay
why do we use the series the
hypothetical series that we missed
before to calculate the why did I even
think about something that's not there
yeah sure absolutely every time you look
at something like I what I'm trying to
tackle is what most people do straight
away which is just 3 and take away in
it's not that uncommon a way to think
about it because I've got an end point
but my my beginning point has changed
i'm so used to starting at one right
that I'll just roll just take away
whatever is there ok I want to I want to
hop on to the fact that that's actually
useful way to think it's good to know
that if you start at one and an
increment up one at a time and end up
some arbitrary number then that's the
number of terms you've got I don't want
to lose that intuition that you've got
but I want to modify it because well I
don't start at work ok so that's why I
think that's a useful way to think about
it because you get it right you'll get
it right